Lucas à présent va prendre la direction
du Loir-et-Cher et oui et plus
précisément direction le quartier de la
bouillie à Blois depuis 2004 à la
demande de l'État la communauté
d'agglomération de Blois s'est engagée
dans une opération de désurbanisation
des lieux question de sécurité problème
au fil des démolitions ce quartier
périurbain s'efface peu à peu s'isolons
du reste de la ville Hélène chapelet
les travaux ont commencé à la mi-juillet
et devrait durer encore plus d'un an à
l'entrée sud de Blois c'est tout le
quartier de la bouillie qui poursuit sa
mutation des voici clables sont en cours
de création et de futurs non végétalisés
vont venir absorber l'eau de pluie de la
chaussée seul bémol très peu d'arbres
nouveau en prévision en zones leur
plantation est réglementée en cas de cru
il pourrait être arraché et venir
endommager cette levée qui protège le
reste de la ville entre le giratoire
Wilson et le fédig on ne peut planter
nous que deux arbres donc c'est vrai que
ça paraît très peu pour un projet dit et
de revernissement de la du site nous ne
sommes pas autorisés à planter plus que
un art par hectare
il y a 15 ans autour du rond-point
Wilson on trouvait de nombreuses
habitations aujourd'hui tout ont disparu
les dernières maisons encore présentes
doivent être rachetées pour permettre à
la nature de reprendre ses droits
nous sommes dans un déversoir ce qui
veut dire qu'en cas de cru centenal le
fleuve la loire doit pouvoir s'écouler
tranquillement donc il s'agit de
retrouver le fil de la Loire et donc
c'est des aménagements paysagers légers
avec des voies vertes pour se promener à
vélo à pied en trottinette et il y aura
quelques aménagements un petit peu plus
conséquent pour en faire un lieu de
rencontre un lieu de divertissement
à terme 350 hectares vont donc être
réaménagés une opération de
désurbanisation unique en France dont le
coût dépasse les 1 million 700 000 euros